[Music]
hi my name is teri Ryan I am a developer
advocate for Google so let's get started
there there are a ton of GCP products
when I went to go put this talk together
I went to go to our canonical list of
all of our products to like ok what
things should I talk about and so I went
and I saw these and then I saw these and
then I saw these and I was like ah what
did I sign up for error this talk I
can't get through all of this right
there oh oh oh and they're open source
funds that we also do a lot with so I
can't get through all of this so what is
what is my goal here with this talk my
talk is to give a tour of GCP from the
perspective of someone coming to gcp for
the first time right so what are these
things what are all these hexagons what
do they all mean a secondary goal but
not something I'm gonna get to is
explaining all the various things
they're available in Google Cloud I just
literally cannot do it and a lot of this
like there are a lot of individual
slides I have here that are actually
placeholders for an entire talk I give
somewhere else like when I get into
compute server list versus VM vs.
containers like that's a whole talk on
into itself so I'm gonna try to point
you all in the direction of where you
want to find the things that you want to
do and hopefully that'll be good for
everyone in the room so one of the
resources that I use to build this
content is GCP and for words or less
which is available that very long github
address if you just you know do a search
on a search engine of your choice for
GCP in four words you will find this and
it's really helpful it gives very
concise definitions of a lot of our
products and where they are concise I
hopefully will kind of help explain them
so let's get started with I think one of
the most important parts of GCP which is
infrastructure right when you move your
work over us you need to run somewhere
you need to to have vm's you need to
have network connectivity you need basic
computing resources so infrastructure is
a gigantic important part of this story
a little a little bit about me just so
you kind of
where my biases are I am by definition
of appdev mostly on the web so you'll
see that I have much more knowledge on
the compute side of the house and the
technologies that sort of complement
them as opposed to say Oh big data jobs
so I'm gonna skip the slate detour and
go right into computing and we'll talk
about the issue I already brought up is
VM versus server list versus containers
so this is one of the first decisions
you have to make where are you going to
run the code that you need to run to do
what you need to do so we start out
first with compute engine which is where
I think a lot of our customers start off
virtual machines disks and network what
do they do what can they do for us so we
will start a compute engine you can get
anywhere from 0.5 to 96 processors and
actually that's actually we'll actually
see in the UI that you can go all the
way up to 160 but you can't customize
them
same thing with memory 1/2 of just under
half a gigabyte of ram to 600 24 gigs of
ram you can attach up to 64 terabytes of
standard disk or SSD you can do 3
terabytes of attached SSD you can add
GPUs or TP use and I like to say they
spit up in tens of seconds and you'll
see that in a minute I'm just gonna go
right to my demo and then if I could
switch over to my machine that would be
great there we go
all right so you'll see here I have a
whole bunch of VMs already but I'm gonna
create a new one and I'm gonna have to
call it delete me too it's like created
one earlier today and let's see we'll
put it let's put it in la los angeles
data center and you'll see that I can go
ahead and customize I can create with
anywhere from 96 I can play around with
us I'm just going to do a basic one
because I don't want to have to explain
that on my expense report
let's say I can choose a whole bunch of
different images a whole bunch of
different flavors of Linux core OS
Debian SUSE whatever you want to use all
and we have flavors of Windows as well I
can do standard or persistent
sorry SSD persistent disk or standard
persistent disk again I will choose
standard and we see that I get a an
estimate of how much it's going to cost
per month great I can open up firewall
for it but one of my favorite features
of the interface here is down to the
bottom I use this a lot I can figure
this in the web and then I hit this and
I get you'll see it's a long string of
text but this is the g-cloud scripting
command to build the VM that I've
configured so I can use the tool to dial
in exactly what I want and then I don't
have to write like out these really
super long URLs that mean something in
terms of what scopes the VM is able to
access I don't have to remember all of
that the tool will do it for me
but I'm gonna go ahead and create this
VM and like I said these VMs been up in
tens of seconds which means what I'm in
my hotel room practicing making sure I
don't screw up in front of you all it
takes like 10 seconds in front of people
it takes like 40 and I'm not really sure
why but my hope is that as I slowly crab
walk over to the console it'll be ready
when I get there oh it was alright good
so thank you for not looking directly at
the screen and you'll notice there I
press the button to SSH into the machine
that's available through the console all
the time I can just like I don't have to
pull down certs I don't have to set up
my own terminal if you want to you can I
don't want to I just do it I do all of
our maintenance through these through
these browser windows and you'll see
here that I'm connecting and by the time
I walk over here it's all ready to go
and I can you know let me bump up the
font a little bit here so you can see
that I'm gonna apt-get update all right
it's starting song software or remember
that I was supposed to do that so it's
to do bang-bang
do it again there we go and so now I've
got a VM that I can start fooling around
with installing software on all ready to
go right through the browser so I'm
gonna switch back
to the present and move on so that was
compute engine now I want to talk a
little bit about App Engine for words or
less managed application platform
managed app platform App Engine has two
flavors standard and flexible and I
think these runtimes are off because I
know PHP can now do seven two so I
apologize for that
so standard and flexible there's a
little bit of difference between the two
flexible you can do more different
runtimes and more different languages
but it and it has open capabilities but
it's not as scalable as standard which
is much more constrained you have to
really adapt your code style to write
for App Engine but you get incredibly
rapid scale out of it and it scales down
to zero so if you're not using it you
don't get charged for it and if you are
using it you can scale up to however
much usage you need to handle relatively
quickly and I'm actually going to show a
demo of App Engine scaling in just one
second here so let me switch over to my
machine and I'm gonna call this up
hopefully let's make sure everything is
loading there we go all right so let me
explain what's going on before I fire
this off I have an app engine app and
you'll see it up the top UI that's this
thing this is going to give it a
variable amount of load it's going to
take that load distribute it basically
do all the math to divide it amongst the
five VMs that I have down there
those five VMs have Apache bench and
they're just gonna hit they're just
going to send a whole bunch of requests
against the the app down there at the
bottom a totally real app and a SWAT
comm the reason why that's obscured for
now is because I want to show this cold
so I tested this last night and I let it
all call a go cold it's been sitting
idle for overnight it has zero usage
right now I want to show you how fast
App Engine can scale from not running at
all to handling large amounts of traffic
so I'll be here at the top you'll see
that I have a request of 10,000 so I'm
gonna send 10,000 requests at that
totally real service there at the bottom
go ahead and send load and you'll see
App Engine spinning up instances of my
code to handle my requests and Oh
something got interrupted there so let
me just ignore that happened huh
I seem to be having issues with this
demo today maybe a no wait
yeah no I'm gonna give it one more try
and then say I should have tested this
morning in addition to last night yeah
all right yeah fair enough
all right well then I'm just going to
punish it by sending a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand at it so I think
what's happening is one of my VMs is
down Oh No okay fair enough
well normally appids you could scale
beautifully when the app I wrote to show
this off shows it off what you should
see and what I will totally go back and
make sure is working the next time I
give this talk is that usually it will
go and scale however many operations I
need it to take and it will in the
beginning the QPS there you see at the
top it's at 3,600 will be low it'll be
like 500 because it is warming up from
cold and then I can eventually get this
up to being able handle QPS is of 8,500
QPS which when you do all the math is
about 30 million requests an hour or
what Wikipedia handles I am sure App
Engine is fine I am sure I push to
change at some point that broke this
front end so with that I'm gonna switch
away from the demo and be glad that my
sacrifice at the demo gods did not get
accepted this morning
so let's oh we're gonna go this way
let's go forward so now I want to talk
about cloud functions we talked about
App Engine which is an application as a
service right you built an application
we scale it for you but sometimes you
don't need a full application you just
need a little bit of code one little bit
of code that will do one thing
enter cloud functions event-driven
service functions what you can do is
have a function a single function
respond to an event and that event could
be HT to http based right so you get a
URL you can
to hit your your code or it could be
something what we call background
background is of writing a file to a
bucket or responding to a message on
pub/sub languages we have a restricted
set of languages here no js' Python and
go but this is another one where I'm
just going to go to the console and show
it directly so if we can switch back
here and have a little bit of networking
so I'm gonna blame the other one on the
network you just have this wireless here
yeah alright so we're gonna go ahead and
create a function and what's cool is
functions will automatically populate
this stuff for me so I can just call
this greetings and you'll see that it
has a hello world message down there
I'll spell it correctly that helps I
have a couple different options I'm
gonna make this trigger on HTTP I'm
gonna call the function hello world
right and what's cool is I can
experiment with this I can yeah I'm
alright thank you go I'm more covering
up for my faults sorry so I'm gonna go
ahead and create this and an error
occurred fantastic maybe I should have
taken that hard wire but too late now so
I already built one of these so I can I
was prepared for this so we'll see that
I have a function here all ready to go
and I have a a trigger this I can go
ahead and write this function that was
the same exact function I just wrote
there and we'll see yeah send something
would you alright so this takes about 30
seconds to deploy and I can have
functions that respond to anything that
I need but based on just one function so
great we're gonna switch back to the
live president and we'll talk a little
about kubernetes engine right so we
talked about vm's we talked about
serverless and now we're gonna go with
containers so how many people here have
played with let's how many people here
are played with docker good alright
that's normal
how many people have played with
kubernetes okay how many people here
have set up their own kubernetes from
scratch the hard way
okay les all right so here's what
kubernetes engine does for you right so
if you are used to running kubernetes
you may you may recognize them this so
you go to set up kubernetes and you
build yourself a cluster of machines
right you want to make sure you have
attached disks to the node machines
because they're gonna need extra storage
to run your containers and whatnot and
then you're gonna go ahead and stall
kubernetes and wire up all the
connections to make sure you have a
network that will allow all of them to
talk you want to make sure you have your
nodes you wanna make sure you have your
masters you'll make sure they're all
talking to one another and then you're
going to want to add dns and service
discovery and then probably someone will
say like how do we know stuff is running
so you're gonna add like logging and
monitoring and then you got to make sure
the OS is all stay up-to-date then you
gotta make sure kubernetes stays
up-to-date
and that's just a lot of work right like
it's a lot of work I made it sound like
faster and simpler than it is there's a
whole doc that's criminalities the hard
way that like breaks people when they
try to do it or just saying you could go
to kubernetes engine and hit that button
that says create cluster and just press
it and like it does all of that for you
and we'll we will manage all the updates
for you all you have to do is say update
and we'll update and that's the much
better experience than running goober
neighs the hard way and so I just wanna
real quick show what coober neighs
engine can do for you so I'm gonna
switch the laptop here and let's give
this another try so I have a kubernetes
engine sorry I have a kubernetes cluster
all ready to go and so the first thing
I'm gonna do here is launch a visualizer
all right all I'm gonna do all this with
make because I don't want a live type in
front of anybody so let's make sure this
is all up and running visualizer okay
and we should see nothing here good
there's nothing all right now what we're
going to do is we're going to launch a
kubernetes install a kubernetes system
here right so let's see
we should be able to see this live no
make deploy sorry make deploy all right
stuff is happening so if we go back to
here we should slowly see my containers
and my services load up yeah there we go
good good good all right so we have
containers I have a little performance
anxiety now right so we've seen my
containers loading up
I've got Drupal I've got Drupal 8 I've
got WordPress I've got a custom PHP
front-end I've got a node app and all of
this is running on the same hardware
it's all running and like you would
never run Drupal and Drupal 7 on the
Drupal 8 Drupal 7 on the same box or run
a version of node on it but that's the
great thing about kubernetes you have
this set set of allocated resources that
you can just keep adding containers on
until you fill it up and then with
kubernetes engine it will actually scale
it for you but I have the databases all
set up in the backend and I have all of
the front ends running and working so
that was a system that wasn't running at
all two seconds ago and now I'm starting
to get IP addresses I'm starting to get
connectivity I am NOT gonna risk it I'm
gonna say this worked and this is great
so I'm gonna switch back to presentation
mode and then we're going to talk about
something that got announced today which
is really exciting
cloud run now cloud run sort of
straddles because if I were to give it
four names four words it would be
serverless but with containers which
seems sort of boxy maroc but basically
what you get with cloud run is you get
what we call cañedo
but managed Kay native managed you give
it any container and we will scale it
down to zero or scale it up to however
much you need to do and we are able to
scale that under load so I'm gonna show
a quick example of a cloud run app I'm
going to show two cloud run apps so one
of the things I'm gonna switch back to
my my laptop here and let me make sure
that I have access and let me talk about
a little thing
that I was trying to do which is I have
a tab-delimited file it's not that
exciting it is all the sessions from
next there's some extra proprietary data
in there so don't like you know read it
or anything it's trust me it's all the
sessions from next and I just want to
take it display it on a screen so I
wrote a little go app that does that and
let's see we we have that in go sorry in
run so let me pull up run here to do do
you go and let's see here's my go app
and you'll see that I have a URL for it
right so let's go click on that and
we'll see the next 20:19 session lists
great right just a little bit of code I
make it show to you but it's not that
exciting it's just string parsing code
but when I went and looked at this we go
down and that eventually someplace it
just kind of falls down right like the
string parsing and go I just could not
get it to do what I needed to do so I
struggled with go for a little while
then I remembered I'm old and I used to
know a language that was really
fantastic at parsing strings really
fantastic at parsing strings but like no
one would build a server list run time
around Perl right that seems ridiculous
but I was like but maybe maybe it would
do better than go at parsing a tab
delimited file so we'll see here I have
the same app you'll see it is Perl you
may not recognize it as Perl because I
did not write it to be as inscrutable as
possible but it works so I'm gonna go
and deploy this code there go we're
gonna deploy that again alright and this
time it works or see how long it takes
to push a container to cloud run so
there we are
and Shh
should be that now oh not gonna work
okay good all right so we can go back to
cloud run here go back and we'll see
that I have a version of this pearl I'm
gonna go ahead and go to this API oh
that's all right
no no main dot PL right because that's
ugly
there we go and here we are we have the
ten eleven aside but what happens we
scroll down oh look look at that that
pearl did it perfectly pearl did it
fantastically now what I love about this
is one I get to make fun of go which I
love I do love go but I do like making
fun of Gophers but the other thing here
is that like we all have this kind of
code lying around right that like some
you know someone wrote 20 years ago and
it's 110 years ago and is still like
being maintained still needs to run and
we would like to get it off of our
machines
I got a you know however old pearl is
down running on cloud run and solving my
problems without having to do a lot of
work to get pearl running on cloud run
so that's what I love anything you bring
to cloud run will just run and that's
really fantastic and free alright great
so I am going to go back to my present
and now we have a question asked it's
like which do I choose right like I've
got containers they got VMs and I've got
service which one do I choose and that
is like I said and like an entire talk
on its own but let me try to give you
like kind of the bullet points of this
if you've got a lot of stuff in VMs and
VMs or the gravity that are holding you
to being on Prem and you want to move to
cloud well then I would just go with
compute engine just do migrations to do
VMs and fine especially if you have a
large number of systems people if you're
in a shop that's more systems than dev
like it totally makes sense to go to two
VMs and not switch over if you have a
lot of developers and you have a lot of
greenfield projects it's a lot easier to
start greenfield projects on serverless
than it is to start it on your own
hardware so that would kind of lend you
towards going service if you have a good
mix of both content of both systems
people and developers and you're looking
to get the most out of the hardware like
you're the most out of your spend for
for your resources container and
container engine is the way I would go
and one of the advantages of container
containerization is one preparing your
apps to run on containers pretty much
matches what you need to do to run them
on serverless except the whole docker
part but especially with of advent of
cloud run running in containers you can
choose to run on kubernetes you can
choose it a run on cloud run you can
choose to run it on docker you can
choose to run a whole bunch of different
platforms so what in doubt I would say
containers is probably the way you want
to go for now server lists I think is
eventually going to be what everyone
wants to do I think it is today I like
what a lot of developers want to do but
there's there's things blocking people
from going but I think I think so a lot
of VMs
stick with compute engine if you have a
lot of developers go with service if you
a lot of systems people and a lot of
developers you can go with containers
with the added thing if you can learn
containers now it would make future
transitions for you much easier no
that's a lot condensed to different
slide alright so I'm gonna switch gears
here and now talk about networking one
of the things that we are proudest about
about Google cloud and our
infrastructure is we have our own
private network so that when you are
transmitting data between our services
it transmits completely on our network
before it ever touches the the public
Internet and we can route stuff all
around the world so if you are a user in
Australia and you request a resource in
North America what's going to happen is
the request is going to go to a local
point of presence in Australia for us
and then travel along our network to
North America and then back and what
this does is it provides you get
shielded from a lot of the bursty nature
of Internet traffic because our network
is a little bit more consistent and you
get pretty good therapod through that
back-end Network and I actually want to
show a little demo of an app that we
built to kind of show the
off so if we could switch back to the
laptop okay so what I'm gonna do is I
have a picture I have a headshot on my
desktop that I took earlier so there I
am right there's me we're gonna send me
around the world so I'm gonna send
prepare we're connecting and then we're
gonna be able to see this travel in real
time across our network BAM we're done
so that transmitted that going from
Taiwan to Tokyo to Sydney to Oregon to
Iowa to Virginia to London to Frankfurt
to Sao Paulo
took four point two four seconds on our
network and what's great about the setup
that we have for this is one that's
that's fairly good that we were able to
send this message across and we stamped
in all the places each we had a VM in
each location that took the image in
stamped it and then send it on to the
next spot
what's really great about this is that I
didn't have to like set up any network
thing to make this happen if you have
your VMs on are in one of our projects
they can automatically talk to one
another so you don't have to like go to
different consoles or different parts of
the world you can just have all of your
VMs in one place and wire them up to
talk to one another just by adding them
to the same project if you want to play
with this we actually have a full
version of this out in the dev lounge
sorry the devs own and you can actually
get selfies that print out and your
picture has travelled around the world
and and you can take that home as a
souvenir
so I'm going to switch back to the
present
all right now some basic things that
people want from the network here they
want load balancers right we have load
balancers we divide them into HTTP SSL
which you would think of as more as an
l7 load balancer we also have Network
load balancers which is what you think
of as an elf or load balancer you can
also set up the load balancers to be
internal only so that you can only have
traffic you don't have to expose your
services to the world to get them to be
load balanced we have firewalls pretty
easy to set up you set up a rule open
port 3306 you give that rule a name
MySQL you apply that tag that name to a
machine and it'll open up that port on
that
machine relatively easy to do and pretty
simple to go through we also have cloud
virtual network so if you want to
configure routes to handle communication
between you between your Google cloud
instances and another location you can
do that we have cloud interconnect if
you have enough traffic that you would
like to directly appear with us that's
something that we can talk about it is
obviously something where there's a hot
a lot of upfront cost but the advantage
is is once you start that pipeline going
you can transmit large amounts of data
for a better better experience VPN we do
provide VPN but its gateway to Gateway
only this isn't for hooking of road
warriors this is basically used to
connect you to another set up someplace
securely with your your own tunnel in
place CDN we do have a CDN if I wouldn't
think this is not like say competitive
with Akamai this is like you just want
to add some edge caching to your your
work you can do that you set up through
our load balancers they will use HTTP
headers to determine whether or not
stuff's cash you can invalidate stuff
but if you need more advanced tools you
probably want to go with one of our
partners instead of just the cloud CDN
also DNS I love this because it
irritates the lawyers whenever I give
this talk because it is the only product
we have that has a hundred percent SLA
and every single time I gave it the
lawyers say there you can't say that and
I was like it says it right there on the
webpage I'm saying it's the only product
we have that is 100% SLA so you can run
your DNS off of our network and our name
servers do have a hundred percent SLA
which means that if you go with this and
we have an outage don't mention me in
your lawsuit I think is what was
comically they're coming from what I
just said right all right we're gonna
move gears to storage so storage we
basically divided into structured or
unstructured storage structured are
things like data application data user
data and unstructured things like files
and blobs and and pictures and and other
things so we'll start with unstructured
and we'll start with cloud storage cloud
storage is object storing and serving if
you want to have a giant bucket where
you put all your files and serve them up
to the world this is the way you would
do it
divide this kind of into three areas
public content processed data and
long-term storage so we look at the
chart public data we have at the bottom
there multi-regional storage it is
99.95% available it's geo redundant so
this is for web console you want to push
to your users as close as possible so
that they get the fastest pull down of
the data that you possibly can give it
is 2.6 Giga bytes percent sorry 2.6
cents per gigabyte per month to store it
there now that's for public facing data
if you have large data jobs right you've
got log files or batch data that you
want to run a lot of computation on you
don't necessarily need it close to your
users you need it close to the machines
that are gonna do that work so you can
go with regional where the data will
stay in one region but it's okay because
you're gonna set your VMs up there to
prot to churn through them there and so
they're only gonna be or like let's say
you're just a regional you have a
regional presence and you don't want to
necessarily serve the world you can just
set up your data here now it's important
to note that just because it's regional
doesn't mean it's only available in that
region it just means that it will be
faster served in that region than
somewhere else it's still worldwide
available if you wish it to be it's
cheaper two cents per gigabyte per month
and so that's that's regional now we
have two long-term storage
implementations one is what we call
Nearline which is 99% available it's got
a 30-day minimum which means you can put
data in and delete it in under 30 days
but we're gonna charge you as if you
left it there the entire time but you
can absolutely delete it that's totally
fine so one cent per gigabyte per month
and unlike the other ones there is a
charge for pulling data out so if you
are if you envision needing this data
multiple times what you'd probably want
to do is pull it out leave it someplace
instead of pulling it out repeatedly so
it's for things like backup or maybe
long term long tail multimedia that's
not getting a lot of use now just leave
it there and have it be stored cheaper
the final one is code line which is our
cheapest it's 99 available just like
co-linear line it's got a 90 day minimum
storage again you can pull it out
earlier but we'll just charge you and
this is for things like disaster
recovery or compliance archives right
things that you really hope you never
have to pull back out because if you do
you probably have like a resume open in
another window right disaster recovery
of compliance archive to things that
like are not happy making but if you
have to at least it's the cheapest one
to store and you will not chat kind of
complain about the five cents per
gigabyte to pull it out right because
you've got bigger problems but the
incentive here is to try to push you
towards making sure that you're using it
the way we kind of envisage it this is
not like this is not pulling stuff in
and out very quickly this is you know
for for disaster recovery and compliance
all right we also have another thing
called cloud file store which I'm not
really going to go too much into because
it's basically just a managed NFS server
right do you need a file system do you
need multiple machines look at the same
file system there you go we have this
product if you really if you need an NFS
server this is what you need great so
now I'm gonna talk about sequel no
sequel are actually I'm not gonna talk
about sequel versus no sequel because I
don't want any part of that argument I
have my preferences you have your
preferences let's all just agree to be
friends and not get into a no sequel is
web-scale
discussion so we'll start with no sequel
we have two products here cloud
datastore which is a horizontally
scalable document DB and we have cloud
firestore which is a strongly consistent
service document DB and you might one
say I don't think the - makes that
forwards and I agree the other thing you
might say is these two things if I look
at them like they're really similar you
know they're both document DB's they're
both you know sorry horizontally
scalable versus strongly consistent
alright so what is the difference
between these two things basically
datastore is a little bit more capacity
a little bit more scale a little bit a
little bit more robust firestore is
based off of data store but with the
firebase kind of api's on the front end
which means one there's really great
connectivity to local clients so the the
SDK for this for writing to mobile and
web is I think really really fantastic
and easy to use and it has real time
capabilities in fact that network demo
that I showed we were seeing in real
time at hopping from place to place that
was powered by fire store because I
needed that for the real time kind of
aspect of the experience okay so then we
have cloud sequel managed MySQL and
Postgres that's what it is it's like
it's just mad as these things you don't
have to worry about maintenance or you
know you could still do all the DBA
tasks you might need to do but you don't
really have to do the system's work to
keep that machine running
so that's cloud sequel and then we have
finally cloud spanner which is
horizontally scalable relational
database which it basically combines
some of the best features of no SQL
which is the the fact that you can shard
it separate it a bunch of a whole bunch
of different instances and have that
drive better performance and better
better scale but it comes at a cost
which is it is not like a it's more of a
BMW than a Volkswagen if you know what
I'm saying
so if you go to experiment with it
please watch the the pricing meter
because it's it's a great tool when you
have that level of scale on that level
of client that you need to access or you
need to give access to but it is it is a
pretty robust tool so how do I make the
decision of which one to use among all
of these well first it's easy to split
up if I've got unstructured stuff I want
to use one of the other two one on the
two on the Left if I have structured
stuff I want to use it on the right if I
have pictures or documents or other
things how do I choose between cloud
storage akkad FiOS store this is really
easy do you need a file system and
attach it to a VM then you probably want
firestore if not use cloud storage great
it also if you want to share it with the
Internet cloud storage it's like one
click to do whereas with cloud file
store you're dependent on the VMS the
run to run web servers web server
software in order to serve up anything
that's on there so I would
you want to share it cloud storage is
probably the way to go all right so
structured data let's say user data or
financial tracts transaction data or a
stack of paper which is I don't know
what I was going for with that but
you've got structured data if you're
going with no SQL if you are talking
directly between your database and web
clients I would I would highly recommend
cloud firestore if you're going a lot of
server server communication cloud
datastore is probably the way you want
to go and then between cloud SQL and
cloud spanner do you have a crap ton of
users all around the world and like high
high needs for availability
well then maybe cloud spanner is the
right call for you but you'd really have
to test it out and see where does where
does traditional SQL start falling down
and when does cloud spanner start to
become worth it to you to get the kind
of performance that you can get out of
it
so I'm gonna switch to security last
part of infrastructure and one of the
first things people do is how do I let
people in to the resources they want and
use cloud I am to do that it's pretty
basic you've got a list of users you can
add permissions and roles to them and
that's how you do it the permissions and
roles definitely vary from product to
product and they are done on a product
the product basis so different ones will
have different abilities to do things
for example one of the things that you
can do is create custom roles so you can
take a whole bunch of permissions and
combine them into a new custom role but
that's only available for certain
products in certain combinations that in
mind we also have the ability to do key
management service so if you want to
host your own keys you can like
basically everything on ours on our in
terms of data is encrypted by default
the only question you have is not
whether or not it's decrypted and
encrypted it's whether or not you manage
the keys or we do we'll do it by default
we're happy to do it for you we also
know that you know trust but verify your
you're perfectly entitled to host your
own keys and manage your own Keys if
that's what you want to do all right so
now that's all infrastructure and that's
all the stuff that like you know you
absolutely have to have to move the
cloud we're talking about some of the
things that we can add to the picture
because again we're Google and we have
some experience with some of these
things not intelligence and not me but
that's what we call it so sorry data
analytics so one of the first things
I'll show off is bigquery bigquery is
this amazing tool that allows you
basically to do very fast look ups of
large huge huge sets of data and in fact
I'm going to do one now I'm going to
brave the demo gods once again the load
all right so I'm going to open this
query gonna run this query now let's see
I'm going to show options yeah that's
fine good I'm gonna run this great so
what am i running I have all of
Wikipedia's locks loaded up and so I can
see the requests for everything that's
come in and I can oh no it's not using
cash so this is gonna take a while I'm
just gonna explain what's gonna do
basically long story short I can I can
in a relatively short period of time
look through over a trillion records in
bigquery and come up with the answer of
what are the top 100 most searched
things on Wikipedia for 2013 and 2014 I
do know this is going to take longer
than most people's attention spans
because I hope that had remain cached
but it didn't so long story short this
allows you to search through trillions
of Records in just a few minutes as
opposed to maybe spinning up your own
data job and running it in you know
hours or whatnot but I am going to
better part of valor and switch back to
my present I have one more demo to give
and that one I'm happy about so other
data tools that we have pub/sub pops up
is their messaging bus it's a publisher
subscriber model you do
many communication basically we can
scale the hundreds of millions of
operations millions of hundreds of
millions of messages per second we also
have data flow data flow is a managed
service for data analysis basically it's
a patching beam but managed by us also
managed by us is data proc which is
manage spark and and Hadoop jobs but
with auto scaling so it's important to
note that cloud pub/sub and cloud
storage forms sort of a bus so that you
can if you need to talk between any of
our services that's probably going to be
one of these two that you use to do it
with cloud storage being for you know
unstructured data like just a file
whereas cloud pub/sub will do messages
for you alright we're gonna switch to
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and typically we have three
kind of ways of using ml on GCP the
first is to use our models the second is
to create a model and the third is to
extend and go further with models so we
talked about using models we have some
of our models that we use the most
already exposed in the form of these ml
API is vision API natural language API
speech API translation API there are a
few more but basically what they allow
you to do is you wanted to check faces
we have a vision API that allow you to
detect faces in your in your apps I'm
sorry in your pictures because that's a
very common use case same thing with
logo detection or language detection
translation all of that stuff now
typically what happens is someone uses
this and like this is great it does this
thing but I really wish I could do a
little bit more you know case in point
someone came to me and said they wanted
vision API but they wanted to trained so
it could detect whether or not someone's
face was covered because they wrote
security cam software and they wanted to
be able to detect you know someone
masked coming into a location because
that's usually bad right we all grace
security someone coming into masks
they're not there for fun or you're fun
I guess so we also have this thing
called auto amel which takes some of our
our api's and allows you to train your
own models but based within narrow
constraints and so I'm actually going to
show one and it is a demo near near to
my heart called a pizza thinker so we're
switch over to laptop we're gonna
refresh and I'm gonna explain so I was
trying to teach myself ml and I'm not
from California I'm from Philadelphia
and whenever I'm here I live here now I
really don't enjoy pizza here and if
you're from California you don't
understand why and if you're not from
California you're nodding your head you
understand so I wanted to write like
could I write something that would
detect whether or not pizza was
authentic like if it said it was New
York style at his New York style pizza
if it's Chicago style is Chicago style
so we're gonna see here on my desktop
I'm gonna pull up a picture and here we
go so this pizza comes from my local
pizza place that is very authentic like
I think it's very good for this area
pizza so I'm gonna go ahead and upload a
picture of it there we go and we have an
auto animal model that's gonna go look
at it first its determining whether or
not its pizza or not and then after it
figures out that it is in fact Pizza it
should give me a score and it says while
that is 95 percent New York style pizza
that is good pizza at least according to
me I was able to train this model like
without any ml knowledge I was able to
just you know take pictures classify
them put them in and it wasn't that
tremendously hard and now I have my own
auto ml model that can determine whether
or not I'm gonna like pizza if you want
to play with this this is also in the
developer zone you can go and we're we
have at various times that we're not
announcing we're bringing in actual
pizza and when there's not actual pizza
you can take use it with pictures of
pizza which we know where they came from
but you can play with it and kind of see
how this works it's also a github
project so you can go and download it
and like build your own model and play
that if you want to you know rate other
tools other regional other regional
foods you can do that it's cool I'm
gonna switch back to the President and
close it out so if you want to go
further and like not train a narrowly
constrained model you probably want to
use tensor flow and cloud ml engine is
probably the way to do that on our
platform right it's scalable it's
managed tensor flow where we will make
recommendations on how to run how to run
those those jobs all right so we're at
the conclusions and I'm close on time
but I'm there so there are a ton of GCP
products so we work here we only showed
these products right we didn't show
everything and here we only showed these
and here we only showed these right I
didn't get into all of it but my hope is
that now you have a better idea of where
the tools are and what kind of problems
you can solve with them and certainly at
a compute and an other level you can get
to the resources that you need so with
that I'll say thank you very much for
coming your feedback you probably got
emails spamming you to say please rate
your sessions I apologize but if you
would that would be great and I'm gonna
say thank you I hope you enjoy the rest
of next and have a good day I'll stick
around for questions put them at the end
of my time
[Applause]
[Music]